un warnen vor unkontrollierbaren
nahostkrise mindestens 40 tote in gaza
und die hamas beschießt wie der
israelische gebiete weitere impfungen
kommen bestimmt der korona schutz muss
nach expertenmeinungen spätestens 2022
aufgefrischt werden werder feuer trainer
coesfeld bremens vereinslegende thomas
schaaf soll den bundesligisten vor dem
abstieg retten
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
den 19 uhr nachrichten auch heute für
den sport an meiner seite
norbert könig hallo und genommen eine
woche dauert nun schon der blutige
konflikt zwischen hamas und israel
doch während un-generalsekretär gut er
ist auf ein sofortiges ende der gewalt
drängt gehen die gegenseitigen angriffe
mit unverminderter härte weiter im
großraum von tel aviv olten in der nacht
wieder die sirenen die hamas feuerte
raketen aus dem gazastreifen ab auch
israels luftwaffe verstärkte die
angriffe bombardierte in cannes junis
das haus des hochrangigen hamas führers
als ob er sich dort aufhält ist unklar
fest steht aber die zahl der zivilen
opfer steigt vor allem auf
palästinensischer seite
axel sturm in rahm junis im gazastreifen
suchen sie nach überlebenden und nach
toten unter den trümmern dem stahl den
beton
israel hatte gestern nach zwei gebäude
bombardiert sie gehörten zwei führenden
hamas-aktivisten getroffen wurden aber
auch zivilisten
ich trug meinen kleinen sohn in den
armen ich will nicht sterben vater hat
er gesagt er war das ziel des
luftschlags gas hamas-chef dezember seit
2000 17 führt er die örtliche
terrororganisation
ob er im gebäude war ist unklar die
opfer der gewalt sind vor allem
zivilisten auf beiden seiten aber im
gazastreifen gibt es deutlich mehr tote
am nachmittag wieder raketen abgefeuert
auf israel heute war aschkelon das ziel
in der vergangenen nacht wieder einmal
tel aviv israel reagiert mit
artilleriebeschuss und luftigen die
gewalt spielt sich längst nicht nur
zwischen israelischer armee und hamas im
gazastreifen ab sie ist längst auch teil
des alltags auf den straßen israels
geworden und des westjordanlandes wo es
immer wieder zu zusammenstößen zwischen
palästinensern und israelischen
sicherheitskräften kommt am nachmittag
fährt in ostjerusalem ein mann mit
seinem auto in eine gruppe
sicherheitskräfte
die hintergründe sind noch unklar
israels premier
tritt heute vor die presse und dämpft
die hoffnungen auf eine waffenruhe
liebe bürger unsere operationen gegen
die terroristen geht mit voller kraft
weiter
die hamas bezahlt einen sehr hohen preis
für ihre taten
niemand war ich zurück weder die hamas
noch israel aber alle zahlen einen hohen
preis für die gewalt und in new york
sagte heute der un sicherheitsrat
johannes hano sie beobachten die
gespräche für uns zeichnet sich denn
eine gemeinsame linie ab wer also schon
die dritte dringlichkeitssitzung einer
woche und man spürt dass es hier an den
versuch gibt man zumindest eine
gemeinsame lösung zu finden es ist der
wille ist da bislang ist das immer an
den usa gescheitert aber deren
un-botschafterin heute hat sich doch
sehr stark angenähert an die restlichen
mitglieder des sicherheitsrates
sie hat ganz klar auch einen
waffenstillstand gefordert mann wurde
sie hatte kritisiert die israelis die
unverhältnismäßig auch die zivile
infrastruktur angreifen aber auch die
hamas die sich feige hinter zivilisten
versteckt um israel anzugreifen
besonders bemerkenswert fand ich bei dem
was ich hier heute gehört habe ist dass
die amerikanische un botschafter wenn
nun auch auf die position ein speck und
sagt wir müssen auch an die ursache
herangeht das heißt die dämonischen die
zerstörung und vertreibung der
palästinenser aus ihren siedlung muss
aufhören israel muss das stoppen denn
das sei mit einer der ursachen
die usa sind dabei ihre nahostpolitik
neu auszurichten will sich von der
vorgänger-regierung unterscheiden und
möchte nicht mehr einseitig auf israel
setzen und so sieht es ganz danach aus
ist möglicherweise doch bald zu einer
gemeinsamen lösung kommt zumindest einer
gemeinsamen stimme kommt hier aus dem un
sicherheitsrat zu hoffen vielen dank
johannes hano nach new york nach
antisemitischen vorfällen bei
demonstrationen hat innenminister
seehofer ein hartes durchgreifen
angekündigt wir werden nicht tolerieren
dass auf deutschem boden israelische
flaggen brennen und jüdische
einrichtungen angegriffen werden sagte
er in der bild am sonntag wer
antisemitischen hass verbreite werde die
volle härte des rechtsstaats zu spüren
bekommen corona und den aktuellen zahlen
hier setzt sich der positive trend der
vergangenen tage unverändert fort
laut robert-koch-institut meldeten die
gesundheitsämter 8500 neuinfektionen
binnen 24 stunden das sind 4156 weniger
als vor einer woche
71 todesfälle kamen hinzu auch die
bundes heute sieben tage incident sinkt
weiter und liegt aktuell bei 83,1 um das
corona virus dauerhaft einzudämmen wird
ein einmaliger impfschutz nicht
ausreichen so der vorsitzende der
ständigen impfkommission mertens
spätestens im nächsten jahr werden wohl
auffrischungen notwendig seien
hierzulande haben aktuell gut 36 prozent
der menschen die erste impfung erhalten
fast elf prozent sind vollständig geben
antoine kurschilgen stau in speyer in
rheinland-pfalz sie wollen alle zum
drive-in um sich impfen zu lassen denn
hier gibt es heute über 1000 dosen
astrazeneca ohne termin die spritze
gleich im auto für einen langfristigen
schutz wird das aber nicht reichen wir
müssen uns wohl auf regelmäßiges impfen
einstellen
da begann es nicht zwei gründe geben
das eine ist die frage wann die
immunantwort die man daher in folk
aufgebaut hat wieder nachlässt der
andere grund ist das virus mutanten
auftreten können
die es nötig machen dass man den
impfstoff etwas abändern
wann genau eine auffrischung des
impfschutzes nötig sein wird sei
angesichts der datenlage noch unklar spd
gesundheitsexperte karl lauterbach geht
davon aus dass der schutz nur für sechs
monate besteht die großen hersteller
arbeiten jetzt bereits an einer
veränderung ihrer impfstoffe und sind
auch sogenannte polyvalente impfstoffe
schon in vorbereitung also eben stoffe
die gegen viele varianten gleichzeitig
schützen können diese neuen impfstoffe
könnten bereits im herbst für erste
auffrischung benötigt werden und das
obwohl bis dahin möglicherweise noch
nicht alle impfwilligen immunisiert sind
eine logistische herausforderung die
jetzt geplant werden muss fordern
experten corona und der schutz dagegen
das wird uns wohl noch lange
beschäftigen
die fdp hat auf ihrem digitalen
parteitag das programm für die
bundestagswahl verabschiedet
in der klimapolitik lehnt die partei
staatliche vorgaben weitgehend ab und
will die steuern auf energie drastisch
senken
die amtszeit des bundeskanzlers oder der
bundeskanzlerin soll auf zwei
wahlperioden begrenzt werden außerdem
spricht sich die fdp gegen
steuererhöhungen und eine weitere
staatsverschuldung aus in frankfurt ist
der dritte ökumenische kirchentag zu
ende gegangen
zum abschluss feierten die gläubigen ob
evangelisch katholisch oder orthodox
einen gottesdienst am mainufer zuvor
hatte bundespräsident steinmeier zur
gesellschaftlichen versöhnung nach der
korona krise aufgerufen die rund 100
veranstaltungen des kirchentags hat
nicht überwiegend digital stattgefunden
wichtige themen waren solidarität der
klimawandel und missbrauch in den
kirchen
damit sind wir beim sport war werder
bremen baut jetzt im bundesliga endspurt
auf einen vereins liegen
thomas schaaf der soll jetzt retten was
noch zu retten ist und deshalb hat sich
der sv werder von trainer florian kufeld
getrennt und hofft dass mit schaafs
unterstützung gegen mönchengladbach
zumindest relegationsplatz 16
verteidigten was mit florian kohl fällt
nicht gelingen wollte soll einen
spieltag vor saisonende thomas schaaf
richten
die vereinslegende mit werder auch als
trainer deutscher meister nun eine art
last minute retter ein externer hätte
vielleicht jetzt doch noch mehr zeit
benötigten die mannschaft kennenzulernen
gefühl für die mannschaft zu bekommen
und insofern hamborns für thomas für
thomas erfahrung für thomas fähigkeiten
auch entschieden
ob werder jetzt fahrt aufnehmen kann
bleibt bis zum nächsten spieltag nebulös
in der zweiten liga ist die
aufstiegsfrage vertagt zwei aus dem trio
bochum kiel und führt werden am nächsten
sonntag direkt aufsteigen
und fest steht dass der hsv nach dem 2 2
3 und osnabrück ein weiteres jahr
zweitklassig bleibt den sprung in die
zweite liga geschafft hat dynamo dresden
das 4 0 gegen türk gücü münchen
allerdings überschattet von schweren
ausschreitungen vor dem stadion teils
vermummte randalierer attackierten die
polizei mit wurfgeschossen mehr als zehn
sicherheitskräfte wurden verletzt
die männer des fc bayern münchen haben
zum dritten mal den deutschen basketball
pokal gewonnen die party konnte in
eigener halle steigen nach dem 85 79
erfolg gegen die alten rivalen von alba
berlin in gelb die schon zehn titel
geholt haben
beide teams beginnen am mittwoch die
playoffs um die deutsche meisterschaft
und überraschungserfolg für
langstreckenschwimmerin lea bei den
europameisterschaften in budapest über
25 kilometer
praktisch die marathonstrecke im
freiwasserschwimmen triumphiert die 21
jährige würzburgerin nach vier stunden
und 53 minuten mit klarem vorsprung auf
die konkurrenz die vier kilometer vor
schluss nicht mehr folgen konnte von 20
kilometer knapp vier stunden hast du
lust er fünf stunden dann genau was
fehlen noch die wetteraussichten es
bleibt wechselhaft mit schauern und nur
wenigen sonnigen momenten dazu teils
gewitter und kräftige regen die
temperaturen erreichen 12 bis 18 grad
das war es für heute danke für ihr
interesse
claus kleber erwartet sie um drei
viertel 10 zum heute-journal und hier an
dieser stelle freut sich morgen
christian sievers auf sie
wir verabschieden uns wünschen noch
einen schönen sonntagabend